Ready to go!
President Lyndon Johnson's War on
Poverty had some important successes, but
it got at least one thing very wrong: Its
leaders used the language of civil rights
to talk about income and poverty.
Financial assistance from the government
is not a right! It's not protected by the
Constitution like religious freedom or
freedom of speech. Using the language of
rights led to two big mistakes. First, it
told people in need that they had no
role in improving their economic
situation; the government would take care
of everything. And second, it led to a
misguided effort to use Congress and
federal courts to impose uniform
anti-poverty policies on every state. Helping
people struggling with poverty doesn't
work that way!
Individual responsibility plays a role.
It's not always sufficient – but it is
essential – and federal mandates often
mean decision makers are too far removed
from what is happening in cities and
states. Our anti-poverty programs work
best when we insist on some effort by
those seeking assistance, and we allow
states to devise the best approaches.
What do you think about Lyndon Johnson's
War on Poverty? Let us know your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.